slaving under the hot sun collecting a
limitless energy source narongchai hoses
down the solar panels on his roof but
when he's done he can sit under the fan
and enjoy a nice cold glass of water all
due to the island solar energy
grid for decades the island relied on
diesel shipped in at Great expense solar
was a natural choice but a hard
sell we asked the administrative
Department local government offices the
provincial energy office and seron it
was difficult and took us every two
years with grants from the Australian
government and technical support from a
team of academics the island built
itself a solar grid now they can capture
and store all the energy they
need Island life has been transformed
the schools now well lit with constant
power for all the students
needs even the fisherman are switching
across to Sol charging the batteries
from their boats at the collective
charging stations on
land but just down the coast an
indication of how most tires get their
energy a huge Coal Fired power station
and massive transport ships queuing up
to offload Thailand staked its future on
fossil fuels not Renewables with natural
gas from the Gulf of Thailand and power
stations burning coal shipped in from
Australia the transition away from
fossil fuels could be relatively easy in
Thailand solar hydro and biomass energy
could generate 43,000 megaw 25% more
than current demands but the government
remains committed to coal and gas
thailands is derailing renewable energy
instead of fossil so if we look at the
policies of our country we can see
clearly Thailand will go directly to the
fossil consumption on the island they're
already seeing the benefits of their
renewable grid homes that used to ration
an expensive electricity now free to use
appliances whenever they
want the peace and Tranquility no longer
interrupted by the hum of generators
friends and neighbors able to chat and
gossip long after dark even the geckos
hunting for a late night snack Tony
Chang alera jig in the Gulf of
Thailand
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer